Elmo has gone viral Elmo like the the
Muppet he's gone viral for
asking how everyone's doing that's it
said H Elmo here I guess that's Mickey
that's I can't I can't do a good
professor Jacob do you can you do an
Elmo hi hi that's pretty good actually
he has a good one I don't I I huh Elmo's
checking in how's everybody
doing forgive the impression that's
simple enough right and there was a
deluge of whining that came out it was
funny a lot of it was ironic some of it
maybe wasn't uh David lit said Elmo I'm
suffering from existential
dread from
hopelessness someone said every morning
I cannot wait to go back to sleep every
Monday I canot wait for Friday to come
every single day and every single week
of the year uh zegler Rachel zegler who
is that she's playing the new Snow White
in the Disney movie she goes resisting
the urge to tell Elmo I'm kind of sad
and so some of these are funny some a
lot of these are funny and good good
responses but I just responded I said
I'm doing doing very well thank you for
asking
because whatever happened to suffering
in silence huh whatever happened to kiss
it up to God and keep your mouth shut
and have a step upper lip what I know
that a lot of these are jokes but I have
noticed people whine and complain about
their own supposed suffering all the
time and we know we live in a victim
economy now where being able to claim
some struggle will will get you more
social currency and so everyone does it
all the time and it's really annoying I
have to catch myself oh I'm tired I oh I
don't have any more cigars oh I oh no
the cigar bar closed before I finish
rapping my show in Santa Barbara so I'm
not going to be whatever it is okay I'm
just using hypotheticals here you got to
cut it out complain it's like it's like
radon in a home you know it just kind of
per it's poison that you don't really
notice right away and it just ah it just
makes you sick and cut it out when Elmo
asks you how you doing you say you say
I'm doing well thank you Elmo how are
you right now go to expressvpn.com
Michels show do you know what big Tech
and big government have in common they
both want to silence any dissenting
voice into submission let's say that you
are a proud gun owner you want to talk
on social media about your right to bear
arms well chances are that your post
will be flagged by a Content moderator
and you might end up on some kind of
government watch list to fight back
against having your voice censored by
both big Tech and big government I
recommend checking out expressvpn in
order for big Tech to censor you they've
got to be able to track everything you
do online your search history the videos
you watch everything you click then they
match that online activity to your true
identity using your device devic's
unique IP address with expressvpn they
can't see your IP address at all it is
essentially anonymized expressvpn is by
far the best VPN I have tried I really
trust them it's rated number one by
Business Insider and countless other
Tech Publications it's so simple even I
can use it and I really like it I get it
on my uh La laptop on my tablet on my
phone and then boom you click one button
and you're totally protected go to
expressvpn.com
michelow get three extra months for free
while you're at it EXP rvpn
docomo expressvpn.com michelow to learn
more there is a story that went viral
yesterday about a young man I think a
32-year-old man who beheaded his father
allegedly picked up the head in a bag
made a YouTube video about it ranting
about all sorts of Politics the video
was up for hours on YouTube before it
got taken
down the father obviously is dead and
luckily the son has been captured the
story went viral one it's so gruesome so
sensationalist but two because the kid
kid he's 32-year-old man started uh
making all sorts of political claims and
so it's Being Framed by the media as
though he were a right-wing Trump
supporter because he attacked Joe Biden
and he attacked the government and all
the rest uh in the video the reason that
it's it's not going to take total hold
is in the video the guy apparently also
attacks Donald Trump and threatens
Donald Trump
so the media are going to spend a few
days trying to make this into a
political issue apparently the young man
was known to the FBI and you know
another one slips through the cracks I
guess uh they're going to try to make
this into a political issue it is a
reminder that there is more to life than
Republicans and Democrats there is more
to politics even than the left and the
right what was This Guy's political
ideology I don't know he certainly said
things that sound right Wing but then he
also threatened the Republican nominee
for president and he said he was the
leader of a cult and he was just
obviously a complete Looney Tune there
is a reality Beyond ideological
bickering and that reality is mental
illness legitimate mental illness not
not what the Liberals would say which is
that uh you know if you're if you want
to vote for a republican you know you
need to go to a psychiatrist but real
mental illness where you think you're
the second coming of the Messiah as this
guy did and where you're engaging in all
sorts of bizarre attention-seeking
behavior for a very long time and then
where you ultimately commit a heinous
evil crime and then make a big show
about it also why I'm not going to play
any of the video or say his name or any
you know that's obviously something he
was after in as much as he had rational
faculties and he doesn't seem to have
had much of those there's a reality of
mental illness and there's a reality of
evil and sometimes there's some overlap
there those are distinct
things mental illness is real and
demonic possession is real and they
don't always overlap sometimes it's one
sometimes it's the other sometimes the
distinction gets a little bit blurry
sometimes these things are brought on by
certain behaviors the kid talked a lot
about apparently how he smoked pot I
keep calling him a kid because it's he's
he's old though you know he's 32 years
old did his drug use have something to
do with it I who knows there is there is
a reality here and and ironically that's
what we won't talk about we never talk
about the existence of evil and really
modern fashionable people they can't
accept it because if you accept the
existence of evil you have to accept the
existence of good if you can exist if
you can accept the reality that some
things are better than other things then
there has to be a maximal good if
there's a moral order if there's a moral
law then there has to be a moral
lawgiver and you have to accept God and
that comes with certain uh requirements
the yoke is easy and the burden is light
but there is a yoke there there are some
requirements there we can know the
existence of God through our reason but
to know more about God and how to
worship him and you know religion this
thing that we treat in a very glib way
these days by protecting supposed rights
for satanists for edgy Reddit Edge Lord
satanists uh but when we know things
through our reason then there are
implications to that and we follow that
thread through Revelation continuing to
test our reason and we talk about U our
religious duties yeah that's all out the
window
none of the fashionable people do that
ironically though we don't even talk
about mental health we we have really
glib shallow articles about how you must
have a screw loose if you vote for a
Republican and then we pretend that
obvious body dysmorphia is totally
normal especially in the and as well as
deviant behaviors and desires we say
that's totally normal and then we move
along move along and then we try to say
that a horrific heinous crime that goes
viral we say oh it's cuz he's a
right-winger you know and then some
people people on the right will say no
he's a left Winger say no he's he
watched too many Ben Shapiro videos or
no he watched whatever some guy on the
left I don't even know who are the guys
on the left there was that guy destiny
that Ben just Deb I don't know whoever
they say he watched too many of his
videos there's more guys there's a
little bit more to life than that but
the more we ignore that the more we can
expect to see bizarre episodes and
really evil episodes such as this man
what a great clip that was now hold up
ring that Bell sub subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time